[Música]
eu gosto muito da natureza e atividades
ao ar livre durante muitos anos física
lava e rocha o que significa
literalmente abraçar granitos e
calcários mas como bioquímico sempre
achei muito curiosa uma certa e ver que
está a cerca dos produtos naturais que
sua bondade intrínseca um produto
natural é bom porque é natural em um
produto químico é mau porque isso não é
necessariamente provado sabe que não
gera muita simpatia vir aqui falar
destas coisas da natureza como se eu
fosse o dólar por do sol o sol o sol é
um nível classificado assim com a
agência internacional de investigação o
inquérito a um nível mais um fato que
são certas alturas do dia é conveniente
usar um protetor solar e um protetor
solar não é mais do que uma mistura de
substâncias químicas capazes de absorver
a radiação ultravioleta
mas o que é que é um produto natural da
pele se constrói é dispensável quando
pensamos em produzir trás
são todos naturais no sentido em que são
produzidos por natureza
mesmo nós não existe
o mesmo se pode dizer da morfina e da
cicuta todos nós desapareceremos a mania
da face da terra
não há razão nenhuma para pensar que
este produto não continuou ele não
continuaria a existir na natureza por
vezes natural fins por opção é que me
mais um produto natural também é
necessariamente um produto químico foi
com os mesmos atos publicados nos outros
através de ligações fazendo ligações
químicas
aqui vemos duas imagens depois de micro
espírito força atômica
são duas moléculas alguém aqui consegue
ganhar prêmios olhar para ela dizer se
elas existem na natureza não é fácil
distinguir um produto natural um produto
que existe na natureza um produto que
não existe na natureza
vamos a um exemplo o milho de
agricultura biológica deve ser
considerado um produto natural mesmo que
consideremos que não foi modificado
geneticamente modernas técnicas de
biologia molecular como nosso concelho
não existe na natureza
resultado milhares de milhões de anos de
crescimento foi de 10 ações cíveis do
agricultor
o milho que existe na natureza é na
verdade bastante diferentes concelhos
mais pequenina tornar as coisas ainda
mais interessantes é possível modificar
geneticamente bactérias
elas produzem insulina humana é
igualzinha a proteína aminoácido deus
constituído por átomos de carbono e
hidrogênio oxigênio e outros
procedimentos médicos
essa excluída certamente podemos
perguntar será que essa insulina
produzida por organismos geneticamente
modificados e também podemos perguntar
um produto é seguro para nossos
eleitoral
não há nenhuma razão para que para que
uma substância produzida por um ser vivo
não seja perigosa para os seres vivos
por exemplo a 71 produzem substâncias
capazes de matar bactérias são
antibióticos naturais como a penicilina
é nós estarmos muito jeito
mas há outras situações em que isso nos
dá assim tanto jeito por exemplo o
principal tema toxina balão é uma
iguaria muito apreciada no japão mas tem
uma toxina chamada tetrodotoxina que é
extremamente tóxica
essa toxina bloqueia as comunicações do
nosso sistema nervoso
elas vão funcionar nós deixamos de
conseguir mexer nos ficamos paralisados
e morremos por asfixia uma 4.000 grave
deixou o suficiente para matar um ser
humano adulto e essas centenas de casos
fatais é uma das substâncias produzidas
que vão servir mais tóxicas conhece as
pessoas têm que ter uma licença especial
uma autorização especial para poderem
preparar este país é uma coisa dessa é
tóxica do titular ou não é mesmo do país
falam
ela é produzida por bactérias que vivem
dentro do país falam o faz disso uma
espécie de associação criminosa e não é
caso único a várias outras espécies
marinhas que também tem as mesmas
bactérias ea mesma toxina e também
algumas terrestres como certa sua madrid
ea razão é sempre a mesma
estes animais têm esta toxina como um
crise de proteção contra os predadores
da natureza não é só paz e amor
a fama veio é aditiva alimentar é
trazê-los ficamos apreensivos sobre a
pane no entanto ficamos completamente
descansados
se formos uma loja de produtos naturais
e comprar o seu momento com vitaminas e
até 300 c é exatamente a mesma coisa
são designações diferentes para a mesma
substância química também soubemos que
nossa embalagem de maionese
ontem o detiveram 260
nós ficamos preocupados sobre os 467
nós achamos que eles querem matar
sob escuta não 2007 é acidente e nós
ficamos com um momento crítico para a
nokia mas no entanto o ácido acético é
vinagre
nós usamos todos os dias para temperar
saladas
é verdade que me que têm má fama mas já
houve muitos problemas pessoais por
exemplo dos plásticos
os plásticos não merece tomar e nós
estamos rodeados de deus na nossa vida
está completamente rodeada plásticos
nós não conseguimos imaginar a nossa
vida sem plásticos na casa do ano nós
vamos tomar nos curtindo o show é de pvc
é um tipo de plástico da organização
provém água também é de pvc outro tipo
de plástico
vamos lavar os dentes e nossos
companheiros terceira das mágoas que um
tipo de plástico mas pensar nos banhos
com a situação sem tomadas não só a
semana do mar porque eles vieram
substituir materiais naturais produção
escassa como masai até os animais podem
sentir naturais permitindo assim
libertar as passas agrícolas por outras
finalidades
mas talvez não haja nenhum um carro mais
paradigmático da importância das
substâncias químicas produzidas pelo
homem do jogo sintéticos no início do
século todos os fertilizantes utilizados
na agricultura que decorre directamente
da química do corda o nosso estilo de
vida que é muito exigente percurso e
produz muito invasivos
de facto neste século 20
nós temos um problema na agricultura tem
a ver com o facto de usar todos os
fertilizantes utilizados eram
fragilizante naturais têm origens
naturais eram os incrementos de animais
e essas fotos são escassas
havia um problema de produtividade
agrícola na europa por causa do show
fundamentais para a produtividade
agrícola
eu tenho uma função uma função muito
importante desenvolver
tá cheio do outro na rodada que mais
existe na atmosfera
esotu mas infelizmente as plantas não
conseguem utilizar não consegue utilizar
o souto que existe na atmosfera então
foi desenvolvido um processo químico
chamado processo
a bosch que consegue utilizar o azoto
que existe na atmosfera e através do
conjunto processos químicos muito
completos conseguem transformá los numa
forma de certa produzir adubos
sintéticos esteja pronto para fornecer
aos outros as plantas numa forma que
elas conseguem utilizar
estima se que esse processo traz alguma
forma milhares de milhões de pessoas e é
um processo muito energético e precisa
muito precisa de elevadas temperaturas e
pressões também motivadas por isso mesmo
as que não consomem 62 por cento da
energia produzida no mundo e também como
nós comemos plantas ou animais comem
plantas também estima que 8 em cada 10
afi o juízo do nosso corpo foram
arrancadas da atmosfera pelo processo
raboch portanto não é fácil evitar os
produtos das substâncias produzidas pelo
homem mesmo motorista é mais frágil
traga o seu corpo e mensagens dos outros
recados atmosfera pelo processo a voz e
com toda probabilidade do amor aos
dentes com cervejas mágoa porque se
calhar cultural natural é não lavar os
dentes está que importa esta distinção
entre natural e não natural desde o
século 17 quando não são científicas que
temos vindo a perceber com cada vez mais
clareza que o homem faz parte da
natureza
um exemplo muito claro disso é o código
genético da linguagem em que estão
inscritos os gêmeos é universal
todos os seres vivos o partilha é por
causa disso que nós conseguimos
introduzir um gênero humano é uma
bactéria e por bactéria produzir
insulina humana
também abordamos o nosso corpo muitas
bactérias especialmente nos intestinos e
ela está em funções muito importante do
nosso sistema digestivo imunitário
a ciência tem vindo a mostrar cada vez
com mais clareza
como nós estamos ligados à natureza e
como fazemos parte dela
agora pensemos um dia de um castor o de
um castor faz parte da natureza faz
parte da paisagem
no entanto ela é o resultado direto da
ação dos genes do tesouro
se pensarmos numa barragem ela também eu
voltar direto da ação dos nossos gênios
sendo assim é natural natural é uma
designação comercial em consistentes que
ninguém realmente controla por vezes os
produtos apresentados como naturais não
têm quaisquer garantias se quer instalar
drenos
é o caso por exemplo de muitos remédios
hamas plantas que são vendidos como
produtos naturais
num estudo publicado em 2003 foi
analisado o conteúdo dos médios as
plantas à venda nos estados unidos e
chegou à conclusão que 59% dos remédios
que contenham plantas não listadas no
rótulo para onde também continham
contaminantes alguns deus perigosos
este tipo de inconsistência é
completamente seria praticamente
impossível existir esse tipo de
inconsistência do medicamento normal
lá pelas autoridades de que menos têm
auditorias e fiscalizações constantes é
todo o processo de produção e
comercialização desde que menos importa
a distinção entre natural é natural essa
é uma decisão que não têm uma base
científica na realidade já vimos que há
casos difíceis como meio de agricultura
biológica é que não sabemos vai ser
natural não
e também a cas substâncias que são
produzidas por seres vivos mas que são
extremamente tóxicas por outros seres
vivos disse é relaxar
não temos que estar preocupados em
dividir e todas as coisas do mundo é
naturais e naturais
esse é um terreno muito pantanoso e que
nos dá garantias
podemos e devemos isso sim estar
preocupados pois as condições de ficar
sem segurança dos produtos que
consumimos
isso é uma questão muito mais objetiva
para cola se pode dar resposta porque
você vê se um produto é natural não
natural
enquanto isso isso é realmente a nossa
boa notícia quanto a isso podemos
contrair
[Aplausos]